what ups face fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today I am back to discuss
the latest developments in the demon
Slayers story if you don't know why I
didn't make videos about the last couple
of chapters it was because we got over
three wrongful copyright strikes on
YouTube and couldn't upload anything
during that time we fought all the
strikes and most of the videos that were
taken down have already been restored
but it goes to show how easy it is to
abuse the YouTube system because of this
I ask you to follow us wherever you
listen to podcasts whether it's on
Spotify or Apple music
you can search anime uproar audio and
you'll be able to find all of our videos
in audio format you'll be able to
download them and listen to them
whenever you want
even if YouTube takes them down I'll put
links to that in the description we also
have live discussions about the latest
manga chapters on Twitch so I hope to
see you there now let's jump into this
demon slayer greatness and if you
somehow didn't know I'm talking about
the latest demon slayer chapter in this
episode so there will be manga spoilers
this chapter is called sorrowful love
the last chapter was crazy ton zero was
experiencing his ancestors memories and
that allowed us to learn about the fight
against moves on the strongest demon and
your Ichi the strongest demon slayer we
finally learned about how Mouzon managed
to escape UD Chi completely outclassed
the demon king of pop but suddenly
Mullins body burst open with incredible
force in 1800 pieces of flesh flew in
different directions
UDT managed to cut more than 1500 pieces
of flesh but the rest allowed Luzon to
fully regenerate the remaining pieces
were too small according to you at Ichi
so I truly wonder how our present-day
demon Slayers will possibly be able to
kill Mouzon if he tries to use this move
my guess is that working together they
might have a shot of cutting down all
the pieces or they'll somehow trap him
making it impossible for the pieces of
flesh to get away but whatever happens
it's vital that tundra will manage to
figure out about this escape method now
there's actually a chance that they'll
be able to figure out a strategy to
prevent Mullins escape this leads me to
believe that moves on probably won't
escape this time as some fans have
predicted so now there's a matter of
this
after the cover page is a person trapped
behind wooden bars their face hidden
then we quickly jump into the action we
are now back in the present day and
moves on is going ham
he's using his demon tentacle whips to
pretty much destroy everything around
him Gio made the strongest pillar notes
that moves on is getting even faster and
that he can't even get a feel for his
attacks that's saying a lot coming from
someone as skilled as gilman keep in
mind it's been a long time since you deg
face moves on so moves on is probably
significantly stronger than he even was
back then we have Guillaume a guru guru
sana me and Mitsui all doing their best
and they're still getting outclassed
meet so he seems to be getting the worst
of it she gets another injury and cries
out she can't see moves on at all and
she's been relying on intuition and luck
to dodge she knows that she'll be the
first one taken out and thinks that
she's been no help at all I love meets
with me as a character she always wants
the help and has the best of intentions
she's always doing everything she can
even though she seems weaker than a lot
of the other pillars and despite how
hard she tries she feels bad that she
can't do more
if you can't sympathize with the
adorable meet suti here then we can't be
friends meet sorry reaffirms that she's
willing to risk it all an attack even
though that might not even do anything
to slow Mouzon down and then dear God
our meet soon he gets a major injury it
hits her left arm and the left side of
her face she falls an eagle who loves
her rushes to help her as the other
pillars keep exhausting themselves
against the calm faced moves on eager
hotels a Demon Slayer core member to
tend to me to these wounds and to get
you Shira who is especially good at
healing even after everything meets what
he's been through she still wants to
fight she promises not to hold them back
she wants to fight until the end at this
point I'm really hoping that meets her
he doesn't die we've seen so many
pillars die and if meets what he died to
that would just be heartbreaking ego
tells her she's not enough he leaves her
in the demon slayer core members hands
claw meat soon he begins to cry she's
crying because she thinks she was of no
use and helped the others and more
importantly because she doesn't want you
to die here we finally get a hint
that meatsuit we might have special
feelings for a guru just like he has for
her I don't know if I ever shipped a
couple so hard I really don't it's clear
that meets woody being the caring person
that she is doesn't want anyone to die
but there's definitely a unique
relationship between igloo and meets
woody and we luckily get more
information about it as the chapter goes
on we get iguras perspective which is
rare he wishes that he met meet suti
under normal circumstances but says that
it is impossible for him he has his own
issues and we start to learn about them
there is a self-loathing there and he
thinks he's not good enough for meets
woody he says that unless he dies and
gets a different body in which this
filthy blood does not flow he has no
right to be with her so he's pretty much
saying that he'll never have a right to
be with meet suti we see that his mouth
looks like the Joker's possibly from
injuries it seems to extend much further
than normal like a snake's ego door
reveals that he comes from a corrupt
bloodline that has killed for money they
did horrible things so that they could
live in mansions and in unnecessary
luxury obviously anime fans should know
that the circumstances of one's birth
should not decide their future
but ego seems to feel differently at
this point we learned that his clan had
only females for 307 years until he was
born they immediately confined him to a
wooden cell it's the cell that was shown
in the cover page of the chapter showing
that this chapter is clearly eager to
focus which is good because we
desperately needed one the females fond
over eager Oh a lot and brought him rich
foods
he had more food than he could eat way
more when Eagle was 12 they finally took
him out of the cell they took him to a
luxurious room where there was a demon
with the lower body of a serpent it
looked as if the whole place was a
shrine for the demon and that the family
worshipped her like a god kid you know
his mouth still not horribly scarred was
scared and sweating all over when he saw
the demon he realized that it was this
demon that had been coming to see him at
night then we find out the horrible
truth iguras family had been living off
the riches stolen from people who this
snake demon killed the demon like eating
babies so the family had
offering their offspring as sacrifices
the only reason egor didn't get eaten
sooner was because he had rare eyes they
were different colors and the demon took
a special liking to him and decided to
let him grow into a more filling meal
because eager was still so small she
decided to let him live longer she had
his mouth cut so that it more closely
resembled her own serpent mouth not only
that the serpent demon drank all of the
blood that came from the 12 year olds
new wounds now knowing the truth iguras
started working on his escape he used
the hairpin to slowly cut through his
cell he was super scared the entire time
that they discover what he was doing and
his only friend was the snake Kabuto
Maru who had entered his cell he managed
to escape and he ran with the pet snake
around his neck the serpent demon ended
up catching up to a guru it looked like
it was all over but in the nick of time
none other than the flame pillar came to
the rescue
this is likely an Ingo Clues dad but it
isn't specified man that reminds me how
much I miss that I'm Goku made that
amazing firebender rest in peace the
flame pillar went and saved euros last
surviving cousin however she's mad at
Eagle because eager to escape the
serpent demon killed the 50 other
members of the clan
she says that Eagle killed them which is
probably the stupidest thing I've ever
heard in my life despite how crazy and
unjust the girl's words were they still
hurt Iguodala he felt that as a member
of a filthy family he was too corrupt he
felt that his sins were too deep so that
he could not live a normal life I just
want to say that agudo is totally not
being fair to himself here his sin that
was trying to survive that's not a sin
it's not his fault that the serpent
demon killed his family and his family
should have never worked with the demon
in the first place their behavior was
simple but iguras was not this is a good
lesson that we tend to be too hard on
ourselves
imagine if Mitsui went through iguras
childhood then he would tell her that
it's not her fault at all he would
comfort her and tell her that she
deserves anything she wants
however we tend to be much harder on
ourselves than on others try this trick
next time you find that you're being too
hard on yourself ask yourself what you
would say
to your best friend or even child if
they were in your situation
wouldn't you be easier on them wouldn't
you support them rather than criticize
them and kick them when they're down
take that as a clue to go easier on
yourself
I've used this reframing trick many
times and it really does help you see
things more objectively Egor does not
get perspective on the situation rather
he feels the decaying hands of 50 people
reproaching him clawing at him and
holding him back his hope is to die the
feeding moves on and he hopes that it
will purify his filthy blood it's truly
sad that Agora has a death wish he feels
like he needs to die to atone for sins
that shouldn't even be considered sins
but in his mind he has convinced himself
of his filthiness and unworthiness
rather than telling me to how he feels
about her in this lifetime he hopes that
he'll be reborn as a human and be able
to tell me truly how he feels about her
then it's a sad situation especially
because people do really tend to
convince themselves of their own
unworthiness even meet suti at the
beginning of the chapter felt unworthy
because she felt that she was so useless
in the battle then ego feels unworthy of
her because even though he's stronger he
feels that his origins have made him
undeserving of happiness almost everyone
feels undeserving of happiness and that
is the truly sad situation that demon
Slayers illustrating here in truth the
manga is telling us the unworthiness is
all in our head Mitsui would in no way
think that a guru is unworthy because of
his origins just as eager oh never
judges her for what she perceives as her
own shortcomings
everyone's messed up everyone's made
mistakes never think you're the only one
and that you alone don't deserve
happiness because of that looking back
on the chapter sorrowful loved was
definitely the perfect title for it
and that is it for today's episode I am
so glad we learned more about ego role I
have liked him a lot for a while now and
I'm an even bigger fan of his character
now I truly hope he realizes that he
doesn't need to die before he's worthy
of happiness and I truly hope that
neither ego [ __ ] meets what he died
during this fight and I know that's
asking for a lot but these guys really
deserve a happy ending thanks so much
for listening if you enjoyed the chapter
review make sure to smash that like
button to let me know for more demon
their discussion subscribe and this is
critical hit that notification bell or
you won't know when new videos come out
remember to follow anime uproar audio
wherever you listen to podcasts and come
discuss the latest chapters with us when
they drop on Twitch I would love to see
you there a special thank you goes out
to our patrons on patreon who help us
survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress fitted ala beat Anatole cos ASCII
alpha do angel crews and team Sparky 65
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Steven n grata
a Lola not M Matty Mac 239 makoto-kun
the world Steelers and the school bus
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon calm an Emir Pro and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to her private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes so
check out patreon.com/lenguin
ever way you choose to support us you
can get the same great benefits again
thank you for sticking with us through
this difficult strike situation your
support has helped us get through it we
truly hope that we'll be able to make
videos for you for a long time to come
here's hoping that YouTube gets around
to fixing their deeply flawed copyright
strike system until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]